[Applause]
every school child learns power in
washington is formally divided three
ways between the executive branch in the
white house now occupied by barack obama
in the judicial branch topped by the
supreme court with nine judges all
political appointees
and the legislative branch where the
senate has a hundred members with two
from every state and the house of
representatives 435
drawn from districts across america
this is the formal system of checks and
balances that is supposed to keep the
country on the stable course of
democracy
and yet wherever you go in this capital
of america and meet the people who are
the most informed about how the
government really works you hear that
the system isn't working and that the
voters are not in charge
you hear it from a member of congress
who controls america
an elite group of people who function in
a
stratosphere
globally and beyond the constitution
beyond the reach of government they have
enormous resources
you hear it from an expert on our
elections our politics are being
hijacked they're being hijacked by
anyone by people who are willing to
spend millions of dollars to you know
elect or defeat certain candidates you
hear it from the head of a public
interest group we have a plutocracy we
have a corporate plutocracy and the
rules in washington are written by the
corporate lobbyists working on behalf of
the biggest corporate interests in the
country
and you hear about lobbyists from a
veteran former congressional staffer who
would only talk to us if his face and
voice were altered
99 of the people that i see live in
congress are white men and women
who you can tell are
wear very nice expensive suit and ties
and dresses
and they are going into the republican
offices
i rarely see african-americans here i
rarely see hispanics i rarely see asians
i rarely see muslims
um
it's like
you see these very well-dressed
guys who just came off learjets
and you can tell they're right out of
the country club
and they're going to republican offices
asking for a tax cut of some kind
these are not just opinions this
well-researched book by william domhoff
details how the government today is
being run by powerful elite forces
outside the government
as we will see his conclusions are
supported by experienced insiders here
in washington dc
all of these insiders say that money and
special interests are now in control
they too ask who rules america
in washington we spoke with leaders of
three respected watchdog organizations
that specialize in researching and
analyzing hidden forces operating behind
the scenes
public citizen focuses on corruption and
accountability issues robert weissman is
their president and described how laws
get passed
how does a piece of legislation
emerge how does it become law how does
it get implemented and how does it get
enforced but every step of the way you
really have sort of corporations
in whatever industry dominating the
process why don't congressman the people
we elect challenge the system well they
are products of the system and
so they've got an inherent bias of favor
and look they've succeeded in the system
one way or another
and those who challenge it are going to
have to fight really entrenched power so
of course there are many of them who are
very good and who do challenge the
system but by and large people got to
washington because they figured out how
to make the system work for them even if
they came in as insiders
most of them were quickly educated on
the ways that things really do work in
washington if they hope to get things
done or get reelected and they succumb
to their corporate interests where does
the money come from the top 100 donors
have given 77 percent of the money
going to super pacs that means one
percent of the donors are giving 64 of
the money uh this is a tiny elite that
can afford to make the contributions uh
that are going to be most influential in
this election cycle
this website
opensecrets.org documents where all the
money in politics originate sheila
krumholz oversees it as the executive
director of the center for responsive
politics
i think many of the people who are
concerned about money's role in in
washington and how it greases the skids
for for uh
private narrow interests to kind of rule
the day
believe that the money is
that the members of congress and
policymakers control
uh the levers of power but that the
donors the kind of patrons of these
people
are
operating the strings the politicians
are kind of the visible
locus of power but the but the people
behind them really are um calling the
shots how do we find out who those
people are
well we have
millions upon millions of records of
donations to federal candidates
political action committees including
leadership packs which are their kind of
slush funds that they control and the
parties we also can see money going
directly to the super pacs these are
the uh
political action committees which are
supposedly are only giving contributions
to groups that are spending money to
run independent expenditures independent
of the campaigns and parties the problem
is of course that there's this secret
pot of cash being collected by groups
that do not disclose where the money is
coming from and they are running uh
advertising political ads which are
often quite
damning and nasty and not sometimes
irresponsible
but are highly influential and we have
no idea where their money is coming from
she showed us what their data shows a
small minority controlling the process
with very few millionaires funding all
politics
there are 610 registered super pacs 190
of 95 of them are ponying up the money
for the ads so far
but this chart really demonstrates what
a dramatic increase we've seen in uh
spending on advertising by these groups
so in 200 2012
uh we're seeing over 100 million spent
that's 100 increase over the amount
spent in 2008 and a 400 increase over
last cycle
this is a who's who
of who's lobbying in washington between
1998 and 2012. the u.s chamber of
commerce spent
831 million dollars the american medical
association
269 million dollars general electric
268 million dollars
the pharmaceutical research and
manufacturers of america
admit to
219 million plus for lobbying and there
are many many more
2012 could be a turning point in
american politics because of all the big
money that's literally being invested
mary boyle is the vice president of
common cause
in who is ruling america you certainly
have to look at the people who are
giving the most money to political
campaigns
they are highly influential people who
give a lot of money to political
campaigns millions of of dollars you
know want something for return they tend
to be really savvy business people who
have made a lot of money because
you know they know what they do they're
doing and they don't make investments
without wanting an investment on their
return
it's unfortunate but obviously it buys
media time
it also buys constant
mail efforts
and also obviously you support
candidates who will ultimately come to
the united states congress who may vote
your way
the largest contributors to political
campaigns in america
are the financial institutions uh the
second largest contributors are large
real estate developers
that means that if you're running for
office you have to get elected by
promising to support policies that are
supported by the real estate sector and
by the uh
financial sector that lends to the real
estate sector
and doesn't this really kind of put the
democracy under threat yeah i mean
corporations are free now
due to citizens united and a couple of
other
court rulings to give more money than
they have ever been allowed to be before
and that is certainly a threat to our
democracy because what it does is it
drowns out the voices of regular people
it's uh you know discouraging in one
sense and that
you know the election of 2008 showed a
tremendous number of people who want
change and yet there seems to be at
every turn change is being resisted by
minorities that are very skillful at
undermining
change
certainly 2008 was the you know change
election and
we have been disappointed that there has
not been more change coming
from the white house
now that president obama is running for
reelection he too is spending most of
his time raising money two billion
dollars for political campaigns that's
why robert weissman says this scandal
involves both parties
yeah it's a bipartisan problem for sure
the uh the two billion is just the
presidential race the over the overall
national race will probably be around 8
billion
obama is an extremely talented
fundraiser so he's going to be able to
raise big money the
massive chunks of outside super rich
money and corporate money though look
like they're going to go overwhelmingly
on to the republicans it is so expensive
to run for office whether it's a
presidency or the state legislature
that you just have to go out and start
raising money from people who want
something in return to run for office
the money in politics just doesn't
finance candidates it pays for lobbying
in 2011 there were 12
654 lobbyists spending 3.32
billion dollars on influencing
politicians agencies and regulators
i was with a group of 20 women from the
middle east last week and we said they
want to know about code pink in our work
and i said come to congress and meet us
and we met in the cafeteria and we
looked all around said all these people
are lobbying congress and they think
they're going to have some influence but
the influence doesn't happen here
there's a special place in the capital
that special people go to that we can't
go to and that's where the people who
have money go to do the lobbying
and they also have their special parties
where they pay a lot of money to have a
face to face with their congress person
that's where things get done
the scholar francis fox piven says
that's because of another problem not
all americans can or do vote
uh
very developed very twisted and very
distorted system of electoral
representation
uh it is distorted
not only by big money although that's
certainly very very important because of
the advertising and the campaigning that
it makes possible
a lot of people do not in fact have the
franchise
and even those who vote
are
not represented fairly people in uh
smaller states have more representation
and so forth so this helps explain why
small but well-funded groups like the
pro-israel lobby a pro-military lobby
can have so much impact joanne landy has
examined who makes foreign policy it's
an informal network
of
the people who rule america even though
they don't go around wearing signs
saying we rule america
that's who makes the positive whether
it's with politicians or whether it's
with think tanks or with the military or
you know i mean it's they're all
interconnected landy says these lobbies
are more united than divided you know
they're just disagreements among them
but they're disagreements about
methods not goals you know so some
people think
you should get rid of some nuclear
weapons other people think you should
hold on to them all but the differences
are really
they cover the gamut from a to b as they
used to say the sort of day-by-day
run-of-the-mill reality is that
those who have
high positions in politics and
strong connections with money interests
and the moneyed interest themselves run
the country
we are now on the way to the congress
which now enjoys less than a 10 percent
approval rating from the public you know
how you know a congress person not only
have a little pin here but they never
carry anything it's always an assistant
who's carrying something and all they
get is people who are fawning over them
and you know so they're in their bubble
and they don't recognize i think that
the country is so cynical about them the
congressmen are cynical too i literally
ran into representative john conyers in
a dark hallway he's the longest serving
member he complains that they are being
deluged by lobbyists
are you seeing a lot of
wall street people donating to congress
trying to stop the reforms
i don't you don't see that but you know
what's going on they haven't stopped
i mean the congress wanted to reform
financial you know the financial laws
and it seems like they're being
stopped at the regulatory level by all
these donations from members of congress
i mean from big banks
and wall street
well it will show up it shows up on the
quarterly
but i i have no
reason to believe
that there's been any cessation of that
or reduction and so you get the same
results stagnation
jpmorgan chase has shocked the markets
by revealing a trading loss of over two
billion dollars two weeks later it was
reported that the huge bank jpmorgan
chase lost two billion dollars gambling
on exotic derivative products
in what they called a synthetic credit
portfolio if jamie dimon makes this
mistake because we know he's good
what the hell's going on at citigroup
and a bank of america thanks to the
mistakes by jp morgan which is the
biggest u.s bank in terms of assets
rippled through the financial world for
many it brings back memories of 2008
when big banks risky bets threatened to
collapse the financial system it was
later reported that the bank's lobbyists
had fought against a new rule that if
passed would have prevented this giant
loss
the internet buzzed with the bad news
because this is the derivatives market
this is very important could pan out to
be nothing
largest u.s bank you know best buddies
with the fed um and of course this is a
whole lot of debt
but none of the commentary i saw
discussed the lobbying by jpmorgan chase
you see banks time and time again
getting into problems slipping up and
you've got america's biggest bank jp
morgan doing exactly that and frankly um
the banks are their own worst enemy we
know we were sloppy we know we were
stupid we know there was bad judgment we
don't know if any of that's true yet of
course regulators should look at
something like this that's their job so
you know we are totally open come on
with regulators and they will come to
their own conclusions but we intend to
fix it learn from it and be a better
company when it's done one of the
amazing lessons i think of
everything that led up to the crashes
they can't control themselves even to
the extent that they will destroy
their own industry even at the extent
they will destroy their own companies
the short-term profit motive seeps in in
so many pours of individuals and
divisions and offices and whole
companies they will destroy themselves
so we definitely can't trust them to
figure out how to control themselves
public citizen later played a role
outlawing insider trading by members of
congress on information they obtained in
hearings and investigations public
citizens considered it corruption
the notion that the powerful shouldn't
get to create one set of rules for
themselves
and another set of rules for everybody
else
and if we expect that to apply to our
biggest corporations and to our most
successful citizens it certainly should
apply to our elected officials
especially at a time when there's a
deficit of trust between this city
and the rest of the country
congressman jesse jackson jr the son of
the famous civil rights leader has been
representing chicago's second district
for 17 years
he's consumed with investigating and
explaining how the system was set up
historically to serve states rights and
special interests
i filed an amendment to the constitution
to guarantee us the right to a public
education of equal high quality why
because every american that's in a
public school ought not be in states
rights slavery
in other words the lesson of the
african-american overcoming the
constitution with respect to states
rights was not heeded through time by
the american people and it is the exact
same system that they are stuck in today
and they just don't know it we asked him
why congress has become so dysfunctional
i've never seen it more polarized i've
never seen it more divided along
geographical lines
along factional lines along
economic uh political lines
it's not what the democracy was
conceived to be it's not what it as he
it was supposed to evolve into
and unfortunately the american people
are are the victims of this process how
would you answer that question who rules
america there are
two types of material power in this
country and in the world one is
political
and one is economic
we the people have the power politically
to control and determine the economic
system and there is a
constant struggle between people power
and economic power
we the people control through the
political system our economic destiny
and the economic destiny the nation
increasingly the heavy hand
of the economic system is controlling
the political system and manipulating
the people
who controls america
an elite group of people who function in
a
stratosphere
globally and beyond the constitution
beyond the reach of government they have
enormous resources
they own the media the power to
investigate
they get to shape the narrative of the
stories
they get to
model and position candidates for public
office
and shape an image in front of the
american people an image that oftentimes
does not
jive with reality and yet the american
people see this image of leadership and
they vote for it
only to find out the human frailties and
the shortcomings of the individual at a
later date we met a former congressional
staffer who worked on the hill for a
leading legislator for 12 years he
agreed to talk with us only if we
blacked out his face and distorted his
voice he was scathing in his description
of how decisions get made
this is a great institution but
unfortunately you have
an untold amount of members of congress
that spend
60 percent of their time
raising money and then when because they
got a run every two years which makes no
sense
um
they have to raise
millions of dollars just to be
competitive to go on television
because
the cbs abc and nbc and cnn
charge this outrageous amount of money
to get tv commercials it ought to be
free or very low cost so what happens is
these members of congress are relying on
well-intentioned staffers many of them
were just out of college many of them
were interns
to make major decisions on foreign
policy and domestic policy and
healthcare and
employment and jobs and
they're not really mature enough
he also told us many of the staffers get
bought off by special interests and big
donors
and a lot of these
young
people
are just out of college just out of
graduate school
they have to pay back these enormous
college loans and graduate school loans
they're paying
unbelievable rent in washington dc in
northern virginia oftentimes more than a
third of their income a lot of them were
taken care of out of work uh family
members
so there's a pressure for them
i'm sorry on them
to go work for
the money to interest on k street a lot
of staffers even progressive staffers
have
left the hill and worked for the large
drug companies
work for the oil companies
well it's usually the biggest industry
it's usually the biggest companies in
whatever industry you're looking at if
you're looking at overall national
economic policy wall street is the
dominant influence you know what's
happening the pharmaceutical industry
and you know there the big big pharma's
got caused those the shots um as
as you know within the financial
industry which factions are most
important it's still really the biggest
institutions that set the agenda there
have been polls on where americans think
our money goes in our government and
just about nobody has a clue that people
wildly overestimate how much goes to aid
and of course part of that is because we
talk about weaponizing foreign nations
as aid
and and they're they wildly
underestimate how much goes to the
military
and yet says our whistleblowing former
congressional aide the real problem is
not just corporate power
the
biggest problem in america is not the
corporations
it
it's not even necessarily the money for
campaigns
the
the biggest problem is that the american
people
don't really organize themselves in
their congressional districts to
mitigate the power of special interest
they're not utilizing their democracy
because they don't know how the game
works the donors know exactly how the
game works you give a member of congress
the money they're gonna probably do
what they've asked them to do
so if you've got
millions and millions of people who
voted for obama
or vote for their member of congress and
then that's the end of their political
involvement well that's the end of
democracy
coming up next the role wall street
plays
wall street the banks and the financial
industry writ large is the single
largest source of campaign cash
in the united states and it has been for
years if not decades
next time on who rules america
[Music]
you